皆さんこんばんは
今日は本当にいろんなことを話しないんですけれども
まず最初にあの皆さんと私で同じものって言ってなんだろう
肉筋肉骨そういうものってねー
世界人口70億人以上いるけどみんな同じなんですね
まあもちろん少しは違いはありますよけれども
同じものがあるけれども私と皆さん一人一人
才能も違うし個性も違う仕事も違う
例えば浅田真央選手
フィギュアスケートでね世界中で活躍してますよね
彼女はフィギュアスケートという才能があるわけです
例えば一応選手
ねバッティングら歳のすごいですよね大リーグですごい活躍してますよね
私たちが人を育てる時っていうのはその人の才能や個性を見つけて伸ばす
私も大学で先生をしてるんですが学生と接する時いつもそうしてます
人間の場合にはそういう風に普通みんなできるんですよね
けれども
自然
の場合に
どのようにして自然の良さを見つけて伸ばしていけばいいのか車
私はいつもそういうことを考えています人間では骨とか血液とか
あの筋肉とかそういう共通なものがありますよね
例えば植物で考えてみましょう
植物で共通なものって何なんだろう今日もこちらに来るときにスギやヒノキや
まあいろんな街路樹を見ながらそしていろんな植物を見てきたんですけれども
すべての植物に共通している成分であるんです
それが
セルロースヘミセルロースリグにっていう成分なんですね
これはすべての植物に共通する成分です
そして人間に例えれば皆さんがそれぞれ持っているように骨であり
鉄駅であり肉なんですね
そこには浅田真央さんのようなフィギアスケートのような才能やイチローのような
バッティングのような才能ではないんです
これはすべてが共通してるんです
人間はその才能や個性を生かしてそして素晴らしく羽ばたくように自然を羽ばたかせる
にはどうしたらいいんだろう
ちょっと過ぎを怜美説明しますね
次は日本で最も多い樹木です
でも次の共通成分すぎだろうが檜だろうが
さくらだろうが全部持ってる成分っていうのがセルロースヘミセルロースリグにこれは
すべて共通なんですね
人間の才能に
相当する成分というのは実はそれ以外なんです
それが重量的に行くとセルロスヘミセルロース留任が約80%
そしてそれ以外の過ぎにしかない次にしかない個性や才能の成分っていうのが20%
ぐらいあるんですそれを私たちは堪えから薬として使ってたり
荒涼として使ってたり化粧品として
向かってたり癒し素材として使ってたりしたんです
そしてそれらは
非常に個性的な構造教えてそして特徴的な構造をしていて独特なんです
実は人間がね浅田マンを選手のように
フィギュアスケートで輝くようにイチローがバッティングで輝くように
実は天然素材の一つ一つを輝かせる事っていうのももし私たちが
その個性を見つけることができればできるわけです
けど皆さん世の中には何百という
何千もしか何万っていう天然素材がたくさんあるわけですね
そんな彼からどうやって個性や才能を見つけていけばいいんでしょう人間だったら話し
たりしながらあこの人計算が上手だな
ああこいつ運動ができるなあこの人の才能はこうだからそれを活かせ
ばいいやけれども天然素材は喋りかけてくれません
それをどうやって見つけていくのか私もまだ答えは分からないです
けれども
私がこれまでちょっと経験したことを少し紹介しますね
さてみなさんこれ何だかわかりますか
これキノコなんですねプラスチックみたいだけど本物ですよ
戻しっていうキノコなんです実は私この例4の専門家ですけれども
15年前に私がレーシーに出会った時にはこのね霊視のことにつが何も知りませんでし
たけれどもなんて私がこの練習に取り組んだろーー
実は近所のおっさんが私のところに来てその人はこの怪しげなキノコ私の所に持って来
てシュミ先生
ちょっとこの例し煎じて飲むと二日酔いにならないよ
体にいいからちょっと研究してくれない
押し込むようでルバイって言ったんですね佳子様出ればこれをさんしかわからないので
まぁちょっと女性の方にはわからないんですけれども
8男性の場合はですねネタ60歳以上の男性の場合には70%以上がおしっこの出が
悪いんです前立腺肥大症って言うんですね
で私はそのおっさんがそんなことを言ったから
科学者ですから大学に戻ってすぐ論文を調べたんです
この兵士っていうキノコにそんなおしっこがよく出るような効果があるんだろう
まったく論文はありませんで web 上でも探してみました
けれどそんなことは全くなくじゃあ特許じゃどうだろう
特許にも全くないそのおっさんの本の直感っていうかその一言なんですもう噂みたいな
もんですよあれども実はその噂みたいなおっさんの直感から大きな発見が
されていったんですちょっとあの前立腺肥大症についてちょっと説明しますね
これはの女性にあんまり関係がない男性だけの病気です
男性はこう尿管の周りんですね前立腺という組織がそしてだんだん加齢とともに前線が
大きくなるんですそうすると羊羹が圧迫されておしっこが
出にくくなるんです男性ならたぶん誰もが経験したかまぁお若い方は経験されてないか
もしれないんですけど私はあの小学校の時におじいちゃんと一緒にトイレによく行って
ました
でまぁ並んでおしっこするんですね
でまぁ小学生の私はジョジョ張って欲しくはすごく勢いよく
けどおじいちゃんは
なんか共著長調しか出ないんですね
あ今思えばおじいちゃんは前立腺が肥大だったな
あっ
でそのときの記憶があってすごく高齢の人はすごく困ってるんですね
なので私のところに相談に来たそのおっさんの一言を信じて研究を開始したんですもう
それが当たるも外れるもわかりません
そして
色々調べていったところ前立腺肥大を抑制する成分がここに示したような
もうこのなんか怪しげな科学講座がいっぱい変えてますよね
これらの成分っていうのは地球上のありとあらゆる植物微生物の中でこの例4にしか
含まれていない成分なんです
浅田真央のフィギュアスケートの歳のイチローのバッティングの才能と同じようなもの
をそのおっさんの怪しげな一言から私発見することに成功した
冷酒の新しい個性をつけたんですね
この戻しっていうのは本当は4000年前ぐらいからすごく
あの中国では有名な記録なんです秦の始皇帝が俺は信じたくない
不老不死の薬を持って来いってかしに行った時に火神が持ってきたのがこの霊子だった
んですね
そういう怪しげな噂がいろいろある中でもまだまだ人間の感性というか感覚っていう
ものでそのおっさんの一言で
研究が進んだですそしてさらに
これ久留米大学の医学部さんと共同研究して実際に臨床して行ったんです
そうするとまぁデータ複雑ですけどまぁ簡単に言うとですね
この冷笑煎じて飲めを市古賀島と思ってるってそういうところの発見率上がったんです
人間の才能っていうのは人間と接すればその人の才能わかるけど
天然素材の才能っていうのは分からないですよね
でその天然素材の才能を見つけるために科学者がね
ロジックを積み上げていってやっても結局分からない
今回のように本当におっさんの技です
その噂を科学することによって天然素材の個性を見つけてそれが世の中に役立っ
コレ一つの例ですもう一つちょっと紹介しましょう
これあのね奥様方や女性の方々はご存じだと思いますが
これ何の葉っぱだと思います
これは月経時の発破なんですね
no れるって言います
これ月経中葉っぱで
これがですねぇ
この個性が何なんだろう
って考えたときに私いつもまあいろんな素材で考えるんです
昔からどうやって疲れてたんだ
昔から使われていたことを昔の人たちの知恵っていうのは必ず理由があるはずだと私が
信じ込んでるんですね
打った月桂樹の葉っぱってどう使っています
古代ギリシャとか
古代ローマ時代
勝利サイン
栄光と勝利のシンボルとしてこの月桂樹の葉っぱと枝で作った冠をつくって頭に置いた
んですね
シーザーが
栄光勝利をしたときにもこの冠をかぶったわけです
昔の人達っていうのは一つ一つの儀式に意味があると私は思ってるんです
もちろん私の思い込みかもしれませんけれども
それって楽しいですよね考える
で私勝手に考えたんですよ月桂樹の冠をかぶったら多分
勝利と栄光を感じてそして気分が高揚して覚醒するんじゃないかそしてある時ふとこの
月桂樹の葉っぱをですねピって破って匂いを嗅いだんですそうするとすごくいい匂い
です皆さん
もですね浴びローレルちょっと料理の質にちょっと変えてみるとすごくいい匂いします
よね
あーこの匂いに秘密があるかもしれん
だから10安 seesaa 勝利じゃない
頭に置いたのか欲しい
そう考えて
こんな実験をしましたこれ研究室に作ったんです
香りをですね人間にコースはせるわけですね
その時に人間がどう感じるのか
それを頭には脳波電極をつけ
神殿を測定してそして作業をさせながらその作業効率がどうなるのかそういうことも見
て何とかしてジュリアスシーザーが
ね月桂冠を勝利者に
かけたそれをの理由を探ろうと思ったんです
そうすると意外なことがっていうかやっぱりって思うことが見つかってきました
まず私作業効率調べたんですね人間ってなんかこうやろうとすると長時間やっていくと
だんだんと失敗が増えていくんです
そうするとこの匂いを嗅いでおくと
正答率が匂いを変えてないと正答率がこうやって下がっていくんだけど匂いを変えて
おくと正答率が下がらないんですね
そしてある作業をやらせておくと値段だ疲れてくるけれどもこの匂い嗅いでおくと疲れ
ずに反応時間も長くならないっていうことわかったんです
これすごいな普通こういうアロマの香りって言ったな鍵ラックスみたいな感じがするん
だけどこれは違ったんですね逆ですこのアロマの香りを買うことによって勝利か
なお高揚するそういう公シーザーの気持ちがなんとなくわかるような
でさらに自律神経活動も測定してみたんですそうすると心拍感覚がどんどん短くなって
いったんですね
っていうことは心臓がドクドクとソフト付属
すなわち近況感が良い子さんへ
なるほど安打アルマの研究でリラックスとか癒されるそんな感じですよね
けれどもそうじゃないこの月桂樹の葉っぱに関してはやっぱり古代ギリシャローマで
こう月桂冠をつくってかぶせたのには何か理由があるんだ
あ僕はまたこの月桂樹の葉っぱに対して個性と才能を見つけたんだ
そこには論理欄で存在しないわけです
ただ直感と昔からの使われ方とかそういうものから新しい小瀬をつけて
天然素材の研究を私はいろんなことやってますこれとの本の一つの例なんですけれども
そこでいつも思うのは
人間の才能や個性を見出してねっ
羽ばたかせようて誰もが思いますよねけどちょっと目をずらしてみると
世の中に使われていない天然素材っていっぱいあるんですよ
これからエネルギーが枯渇する中それはどうやって見つけて言ってどうやって役に立て
ていくのか
そこに科学の力が必要だとしても人間が考えることなんて限られてる
人間だロジックを積み上げていっても全然見つからないことの方が多い
それよりも近所のおっちゃんの言葉たがをし雇用でる場合いかーんねあの歴史の本を
紐解いてこんなことを使われてたんだ
それを基に塩灸をすることによって新しいことが見つかってくるっ
私は今の大学でそういう天然素材の研究を幅広く行っています
常にいつもいろんな天然素材をね福岡県内だけじゃなくて海外からも皆送ってくるんで
ねえメールだけじゃなくて電話もひっきりなしにかかってしまい先生こんな効果が
うちの婆ちゃんこんなこと言ってたんだけどやってくんないだからもいろんなものが
楽しいんですけどね
けれども私の研究っていうのは天然素材に注目して
で何で私が天然素材にそんなに注目するのかこれ別にですね私大学の研究室を選ぶのも
全部 g
うんで選んだわけじゃない一生懸命目の前のことをやってたらいつもありか
卒論とか修論とかそういうものがこういうテーマになってたん
なんでだろう最近ちょっとひとつ答えが分かった
私は今自然の言及をしている
それは自分の生い立ちに少し関係があるんじゃないかなっ
実は私生まれた時に耳がなかった
ここね
この耳は
太ももの肉を移植したんですねん
でえっとね付肉だけ移植しても形が作れないでしょ
わき腹の骨お子さんもないんですねを移植して形を作ったん
私が
母の胎内にいたときに
母が
人口の薬を飲んでたんですね
その当時いろんなあのね薬の副作用ってあっ
それで私は生まれたときに障害を持って生まれ
ずっと思ってましたでなんだよ僕はこういう風に普通の人と違って生まれたんだろう
で全然私研究室を選ぶ時もですね
研究して選ぶから教授がこういって言っても私いかなかったんです
そういう大学じゃバトミントンやってて試合前だからそっちに行くって言ったらも清水
ここしかないからって言ってどんどん天然素材に運命がいいね
ヘのその運命がテントテントあったものが
私がなぜそのようにして生まれたのかっていうことと今やってることがなんとなく
つながってきたんですね
例えばこの戻しっていうのは4000年前から使われているわけですよ
砂地精査世代を越えてね
人間に約立ってきた世代を超え者人間が開発しているもの
所詮10年でしょ20年でしょ
世代を越えてどうなるかなんてわからないわけです
もちろん人間が作り出したものでああ
安全で素晴らしいものがたくさんありますけれども私はなぜか分からないけれども
天然素材だけを研究して地下も世代を超えでだってローレルだってね古代ローマ時代
からあるわけです
昔から
そういうものを研究していま使命感を持ってそして自分がこのようにして生まれたこと
もすごく喜びを感じ
自分がこの研究をするための使命を与えてもらえた
で今目指しているのが
それを続けて言って将来万事屋になりたい
案外ですね大学の先生で万事屋になりますって言う人って少ないんですよね
どちらが出るところ小さいところで専門分野を磨いてそれの最先端を目指す県私は何か
違ってて万事屋ってなんか自分の店の中にいろんなものがあるようなイメージがあり
ますよねで私は地球上にあるすべての
天然素材の万事屋になりたいんです
いろんな人たちが身近なものから離れたものまで
エジプトのものだったりねアフリカのものだったそういうものも含めていろんなものを
研究したい
いろんな人たちがどのようにしてそれでこらえから生活が豊かになってたのかそれを
科学的に証明してそして今の現代に役立ててきた
そういう万事屋を目指しでいろんな人たちが苦しんでる人とか病気になった人とか
ちょっとリラックスしたい人たちが来た時にその科学技術に基づいてその万事屋として
それを提供して言ってそしてなんか幸せなることに寄与していきたいなって思ってます
今日は万事屋なるって宣言してしまいました
大学で今はそういう風な研究をしてますけどこれからも頑張っていきますのでどうもご
静聴ありがとうございました